so to recap it sounds like ask questions
don't defend don't be combative try not
to be too passive but try not to be too
much of a fighter
in the room as well find that middle
ground and then find something that you
both agreed on in the beginning take
yourselves back to that win-win so this
week instead of pointing out what you
don't agree with and then circle back
kind of give it a breather well is it's
not so much circle back because that
sounds like you're gonna to attack if
there's a point in the script that I as
a director I'm having a trouble with and
the writer just can't see it and I'm
aware they can't see it or don't want to
address it I'll say okay fine let's
let's talk about something else and I
will go back in the script I'll go back
and either in the script or in the story
and might even be if this moment between
let's say it's a husband and wife and
the script we're having a disagreement I
said okay let's go back and we'll talk
about the relationship and where the
relationship is going and how the
relationship between these two
characters is evolving now I'm moving
slowly towards this point now many times
when I've done this I've come close to
this point and realize oh it's me I'm
the problem because I was seen in a
different way sometimes I've done this
and I've now I'm able to see where the
writer was going because we're walking
through the story either walking through
the script or walking through the
relationship towards the problem area
rather than trying to address the
problem it's the difference of putting a
bandaid on it on the wound or trying to
figure out what caused the wound in the
first place and so you've got to back
away from it and then come up to it
again do you think that's a common thing
for most people to be that aware
software that they were sort of the cog
in the wheel no okay
well the most common thing is people
think I'm right you're wrong fix it
change it change your performance change
the script change whatever depending on
who you I mean if I'm talking about
directors now kids directors say this is
the way I want it's like Michael was
saying before about you know a script is
written and it goes on to a director and
the director will dismiss
the writer and then start to make the
script his own story which happens in
Europe a lot in fact in Europe the
script is sold and the writer is gone
and the directors got it and then the
producer is then waiting for the what
they called the directors script the
director will rewrite it and make it his
script well what happened to the writer
a lot of my friends in Europe are
writers and they said well no no he
that's his job his job is to sew that
which I don't agree with it because
that's not collaboration at all that's
sort of acquisition and then
modification and then it becomes
somebody else's story but if we're
talking about the collaboration process
then there has to be this open
communication it has to be the
willingness as Michael Sainte to listen
to really consider this is another thing
consider the other person's objection
maybe they're right as horrible as it
feels to you maybe they are right or
maybe they're which Michael did suggest
maybe they're onto something
that is right but you can't see you
can't see it yet and maybe they can't
see it but they can feel it and there's
you know in it I think we all have to
back away from the argument back away
from the battle of winning because when
someone again when someone wins the
project loses I think I don't think you
need to be quite so walking on eggs is
you kind of described about it's like
we'll be nice and don't be combative I
don't think being combative is always a
bad thing
but I think what you gotta ask yourself
is am i fighting for the story and the
character or am i fighting for a
specific choice I made that I think must
be the best and I won't consider
anything else I mean when when we work
on scripts together the point you always
want to go back to is who are these
characters what do they want what is
this story about and if you can get
agreement on that then sometimes if you
really think you're being more
consistent with the story I think you
have to stand up for that and you can be
combative but at a certain point it'll
become counterproductive if you just
both lock horns and get nowhere I don't
think anybody wants somebody to just be
sweet all
the time but be very clear on what
you're fighting for cuz if it's this
line of dialogue has to stay that's
being too picky or too too silly it's
more is this the story we said we wanted
to tell ya and that that line this is
this the story we wanted to tell is just
pretty much what I was saying going back
to a point of agreement we're trying to
tell this story right in other words
you've got and if everybody says yes
that's where we are now we're now we're
in a place where all agreeing okay now
let's look at what we're doing in very
possibly the writer the director whoever
is who is fighting for a point of view
can make a very strong case for that
point of view based on this is the story
where you want to tell and it's either
and that somebody is you know so the
chances are that other people gonna go
all now I see what you're doing now I
get understand why it's there or why
it's that way yeah I mean the biggest
difficulty comes when that question has
never been asked what what's this about
I often times when I'm brought in and a
project is well down the road the first
thing I ask and I keep asking it again
in Guinness so what's this movie about
you're you're all caught up everybody
else that's so close to the script
because they've been working on it for
weeks or months or years sometime is
well it's got to be this and the budget
is this and we're shooting here and I
say what is this about what what are you
trying to say what's the overall theme
of this what are we exploring here and
get everybody all the way back to that
ground level idea because if you can get
everybody considering that and get them
all in the same place it will greatly at
least improve the arguments because then
they're all arguments toward a common
goal that would be great
and I also my experiences have been a
lot of when I've asked that question
when I say what is the story really
about I put in the word really they're
trying to get them deeper what's it
really about because I don't want well
it's a story about a husband and wife I
said I know I read the script what is it
really about that a lot of assumptions
that are made even by writers but
directors and producers is well you read
the script
don't you know you know assumption is if
you've read the script you know what
it's about I thought no I don't but it
gets down to what are you trying to say
with this what is the themes what is it
you the director the writers the actress
what do you want to say what do you want
to say with this story if we can all
agree on that you're right then we have
a foundation we always have a place to
go back to say that's what we're doing
that's the house we're building let's
not argue about the beams and the nails
this is the house we're building and if
if that question can't be answered I
think there are other questions you can
ask to get to that like if if nobody has
really thought in that broad way or that
deep way then I would change the
question to something like how do you
see this character usually the hero of
the story just let's talk about this
character and say who are they what are
they about and you want to get to the
point where you can ask how is this
character gonna change in the course of
this story
what's the characters arc what do they
have to learn how what kind of courage
do they have to show because if you can
identify that in my mind you've
identified what the movies about because
whatever you want the audience to take
away from the movie at that level that's
what the hero the story has to learn in
the course of the story whatever courage
that here hero finds is touching on this
is what the filmmakers are saying we
should all learn in order to live a more
fulfilled life so start with the
character if you can't jump right to the
deeper bigger issue what's the story
about one of my favorite questions to
ask writers directors producers anybody
I say you're making this film here's the
script here's the story you're making
this film imagine that it's finished
which they love and imagine that it's
finished and it's perfect it's exactly
what you wanted and they go okay and I
said now imagine two 300 people are
watching it right and the movies over
and they're going home are they going to
Starbucks wherever they're going what do
you want them to be thinking about
worried about fantasizing talking about
discussing with each other and most of
people looking to go no idea
I said we're because I said that's the
power of your film the power of your
film is what happens to that audience
the moment the movies over and what
they're taking out of thee not what
they've experienced during just the two
hours but what they take out of there
and again if we can start to identify
that then we're getting back to exactly
what you're talking about which is
usually the hero's journey or the
protagonists journey and it's gets back
to this is what this story is all about
and this is the power of the story
because I say if you're talking about
the the writing the cinematography the
acting the locations if your film
doesn't work yeah and I'll we're also
now talking be on or before
collaboration I mean this better be
questions that the screenwriter is
asking as they're working on the script
before anybody else sees it
this better be these better big
questions the producer is asking before
he options it or the director is asking
before they have that first meeting
they've got is start thinking in those
kinds of terms and not just in won't
this be funny won't this be a cool scene
won't this make money if only we cast so
and so we'll have a head or they never
think that way no no that doesn't happen
you